on your quest to find love and possibly
have offspring many of us cringe at the
idea of mating with a sibling or any
relative really weird but what's the big
problem with incest in the first place
what actually happens when you in breed
the first thing to understand is how any
trait you have comes about you have your
biological mom and your dad who each
have their own unique DNA and basically
you get half of your DNA from mom and
half from dad these DNA pairs define
everything about you but in some cases
certain traits are more dominant like
brown eyes for example if your mom has
two pairs of the brown eye allele her
eyes will be brown and if your dad has
two pairs for the blue eyes his will be
blue as a result you'll receive one
brown gene from mom and one blue gene
from dad but brown eyes just happened to
be a dominant trait meaning even though
you get one brown and one blue from each
parent your eye color will actually be
brown it takes having two recessive
alleles to exhibit the other traits in
this case if you got two blue alleles
you'd end up having blue eyes so what
does this have to do with incest it
turns out that many specific diseases or
disorders are recessive and require you
to get the gene from both your mother
and father they can each carry one and
be perfectly healthy making it difficult
to know that they are carriers as a
result if your dad has one allele for a
disorder it's pretty likely that his
sibling or relative probably has it too
because they would have gotten it from
their parents or other relatives had
your dad decided to mate with a random
person in the population the chance of
them having the same recessive gene is
low but if he chooses to copulate with
his sister or cousin then your odds of
getting both of the recessive genes are
much higher still not guaranteed but
much more likely in that sense it's
important to remember that inbreeding
doesn't create genetic mutations or
defective offspring itself but instead
increases the chance of a rare gene
combination in fact even when both
parents carry a recessive gene there's
still a 75% chance that they won't both
pass on the gene leading to perfectly
healthy kids with respect to that
particular disorder or disease so
in reading ever good not so much in
humans but we rely on it in some plants
and animals in fact different dog breeds
are the result of reading relatives with
similar desirable traits like coke color
height or snout size but we can even see
the risk in dogs with many purebred
suffering from hip problems eye problems
and more while mutts or dogs with
genetically diverse parents tend to be
healthier thanks for tuning in to our
video that's kind of about incest we
really hope that you enjoyed it there's
science and everything not just kind of
interests it was fully about it yeah
fully about it says if you want to watch
more of our videos we'll put some extras
over here also make sure you subscribe
to our Channel and we will see you next
week for another video